[Music]
overcoming the negative conversation
that inner dialogue is going on all the
time all the time even when you don't
want it to be there you can't stop
yourself right now from thinking you
can't do it it's going on and so
learning how to empower yourself part of
doing that is standing up to yourself
you've got to stand up inside yourself
sometimes and say shut up you've got to
do this I was going to give a
presentation and this voice inside of me
saying you can't do this you don't have
everything it takes us shut up I'm
behind on my bills are you telling me
what I can't do I have got to do it
[Music]
no matter what you're going through in
your life whether it's a large
difficulty or a small setback you want
to ask yourself how can I use what I'm
going through as fuel for my growth
you want to ask yourself what is the
gorgeous opportunity hidden inside this
so-called problem I mean and if you look
at the mass of humanity they really
train their brains to focus on problems
right the hit a wall and then just
because of their belief system they
don't know it because most people are
not really that aware of their belief
systems so they blame it on the world
they blame it on the supplier they blame
it on the teammate they blame it on
their husband or wife they blame it on
their childhood you want to train your
brain to see the treasure within the let
[Music]
the fact that human beings are strongest
Drive is the need to stay consistent
with how we define ourselves if your
self definition is I'm a situation where
I'm kind of what was already used a
shy-shy but then you're gonna find a way
to get to a place where you kind of
cower back the fastest thing you can do
to change your experience would be to
create a new little thing a simple thing
like erased I mean if I'm shy go erase
when you cook calling yourself shy you
believe you hooked I've always been shot
up until this moment do something that's
completely outside what you would
normally do something become somebody
else decide who's the most playful
passionate outrageous fun person you
know and behave like them for two or
three days just push yourself to behave
like that here's what's happened you'll
be shocking you'll be weird it'll be
different you'll feel uncomfortable but
after a while you get reinforced
talk nicely to yourself
treat yourself and say to yourself well
you would say that somebody else to
encourage them that's what I started to
do and the next week had a big game
against the Cardinals and it was in my
attain of 15 years in the NFL the best
and greatest football game I've ever
played and I think it was it was because
I truly told myself you can do this you
know how to play this game you belong in
this game and I've had to use that to do
live how did you do use it to do Fox
because I wasn't so sure I could be a
sports commentator I'm as scared and
it's fearful with anybody else to tackle
something new but I've learned that
sometimes I got to get over the fear of
not doing it because I'm scared instead
of not doing it because I can't do it I
remember being 25 years old scared to
death of people 29 years old started my
speaking career terrified are the people
I had to go to didn't call on anybody
for a year because I was literally
frozen in fear and one day somebody said
something to me do you need you need to
handle yourself confidence issue so I
went and bought a suit and I didn't feel
any better I wouldn't bought a car
didn't feel any better about myself I
mean I felt a little better for a second
look self confidence is the only outfit
you can't buy this is an inside job you
got to study you got to learn you got to
practice and you have to you have to do
the hard things self confidence comes
from repeating experiences that are
difficult it's not on sale it's not at
Bloomingdale's Macy's it's not a Toyota
it's not on the radio dude it's an
inside job I can't help you with the
only thing I know for sure that will
change your sense of self is the actions
you take getting in front of other
people
other people people you don't know
people you're scared to talk to
[Music]
so your problem isn't doubt your problem
is courage doubt is going to be there
but doubt gets out of the way when you
express courage do the thing and you
will have the power right whatever it is
that you're deciding that you want to do
with yourself that you're doubting your
ability on just do it [ __ ] it up
completely success is not doing the
right thing and it definitely isn't
doing the right thing the first time
success is having the courage to move in
the direction of your dreams move in a
direction that your heart is taking you
that is what success is as you are
progressively realizing that thing
[Music]
there's a new book coming up and the
title says [ __ ] fear
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] there
[Applause]
[Music]
because we are born to be happy strong
and healthy not in distance not
alienated not in stress biological cell
destructive comfort-zone behavior
confidence I believe not in the books
now yeah
connecting within myself part right
clear into the unknown is where I shoot
and with Mount Everest
and from there it was very joyous to go
north Col up and down up and down like
ten times
going into the death so my short the
willingness walk into the unknown
without a guarantee that's half of the
equation the other half of the equation
is giving the other person radical
permission to have their first response
to men think is just because they're
taking a risk women owe it to them to be
polite or accepting they go yeah that's
not a contract so giving a woman her
first permission to have whatever
response she wants to have and at the
same time being willing to walk into the
unknown
creates magic and when someone is
walking their path in life they have
power in their personal power it shows
up and how they arrived
it's nonverbal if you want to use a
sloppy term its energetic means also my
voice the way I carry myself so I carry
myself like someone who has a mission
and a destiny that I know where I want
to represent an idea i want to represent
possibilities I want to represent magic
right that you're in a universe and two
plus two equals four two plus two only
equals four if you accept it two plus
two equals four two plus two is gonna be
what I want it to be you know and
there's that there's a like there's that
there's a redemptive power that making a
choice has you know rather than feeling
like you're at a fact to all the things
that are happening make a choice but you
just decide what is gonna be who you're
gonna be how you're going to do it just
decide and then from that point the
universe is going get out your way this
light is water it wants to it wants to
move and go around stuff you know I can
create whatever I want to create if I
can put my head on it right study it and
learn the patterns and I feel very
strongly that we are who we choose to be
[Music]
I'm unbelievable inside the page this is
why the people have so much interesting
on me are you the best footballer in the
world right now
I think so yes in my mind I'm always the
best I don't care what the people
thinking what they say in my mind not
just this year but always I'm always the
best I'm always gonna say that because
you're I think we have to thinking we're
the best in our area so in my area I
think I'm the best is there anything
that Leo Messi is better than us
opinions
I respect the opinions maybe in your
opinion messes better than me but in my
mind I'm better than him so simple
[Music]
I've never doubted myself I go into an
or I'm one of the past month you know
not an even in a cocky way I just feel
like I'm one of the baddest month walk
the face of the earth
you know and that's just how I am
because I feel I am I am what a badass
mother walks face with her that's just a
fad where does self confidence come from
it's something that we seem to know
implicitly whenever we see it right it's
a guy that can walk into any room in the
entire world and no matter who's in
there he feels comfortable or a woman
who can walk up to a total stranger and
start conversation effortlessly or maybe
just someone that you might have met who
doesn't seem to have the hesitation the
self-doubt that plague so many people
but the question remains where does this
self-confidence come from the answer is
that it comes from raising your
self-esteem your self-esteem is your
reputation with yourself it is what you
think about you and that is why
compliments cannot build your
self-esteem that is what other people
think about you
[Music]
I just recently found my confidence
right this year the first year that I
had this like boost of confidence um
and it's because you know like this idea
of what - liz is like burned into our
brain and I just don't think it's I you
know I don't think that I'm starting to
like open up to so many more thing to
see how that many things are just like a
facade and being cool as a total facade
you know so I even even celebrity lies
and all those people I thought were
these awesome people you meet them and
they're so fun charismatic so lame so
pointing it's all uncool so you know me
and so sadly these are the people that
are like making us feel bad about our
bodies or our face or our hair or
lifestyle or our choices like oh just
spare me now so over it so ah you know
what man I say take all this Drive shrug
it off the cool fall off quickly like
those they let them peaked man
let them peak let's that's what I say
let them be
[Music]
there is this higher force above and
here in this planet that is going to
help us to live a prosperous life to be
happy to be healthy to be joyful to have
that peace being if we truly respect and
appreciate ourselves and others in that
process as well well
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what was the
single biggest takeaway that you're
going to apply immediately to your life
or your business to bring more of that
self confidence and leave in the
comments below thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your why where it is much love
see you soon
if you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it don't you
believe it you act like I am Tulsa what
a wail out of a handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I've murdered a
rock into the stone hospitalized a brick
I'm so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between eighteen and two hundred
and fifty four days of taking action for
a new habit to stick I've created a new
course called 250 for confidence or
every single day for 254 days I will be
sending you a video between 30 seconds
and 5 minutes long that you start your
morning with around making you feel
confident it's absolutely free check out
the link in the description below to get
access